on passe à notre second débat débat
décalé plus prospectif débat de société
on parle des jeunes ce soir à l'occasion
de la sortie du livre la fracture étude
sur les 18 30 ans en ce sens ces années
2020 avant d'en découvrir les résultats
parfois surprenants je propose de partir
à la rencontre de grégoire cascarre et
ses amis ont créé le mouvement les
engagés ils veulent notamment lutter
contre l'abstention sandra cerqueira
lots françois je vais les voir caisses
caja j'ai 21 ans et je suis jeune
grégoire fait partie de cette génération
ultra connectés
né en l'an 2000 une jeunesse qui
s'abstient de plus en plus lors des
régionales en juin dernier près de 90 %
des 18-24 ans ont boudé les urnes mais
pour cet étudiant de 21 ans ce n'est pas
une fatalité on voit des jeunes qui
touche à un sujet d'actualité à l'heure
prévue on vise s'engager ponctuellement
pour des causes éphémère interviewé ce
jour là sur son premier ouvrage
génération engagée il explique à quel
point les jeunes se méfie des
institutions et ne se sentent pas utile
en votant des jeunes qui ne votent pas
ça veut pas dire qu'il ne s'engage pas
simplement il s'engage avec d'autres
outils que le vote parce qu'ils ont
l'impression qu'au fond et l'ire des
responsables politiques c'est plus la
façon la plus utile d'avoir un impact et
changer les choses en 2017 grégoire créé
le mouvement les engager un mouvement
citoyen présent dans toute la france
pour remobiliser les jeunes persuadé que
c'est à l'école que beaucoup se joue ils
interviennent dans les lycées notamment
au tour de la prochaine présidentielle
je les tue quand j'étais
crédit existent eux mans on nous parle
très peu de citoyenneté on voit très peu
de politiques et pourtant c'est à ce
moment là je décide toutes les études
sociologiques montrent que un gène qui
votera la première fois où on a le droit
de vote votre quasiment jamais ensuite
dans tous et donc c'est à 17 ans à 18
ans que tout se joue chloé la sueur elle
aussi aurait pu être abstentionnistes si
elle n'avait pas découvert le mouvement
n'en parlent pas forcément autour de moi
ses parents l'ont traité de nos études
s'intéresser à la politique c'était
ensuite on parlait beaucoup à tapha
raison
les années du lycée n'est pas très
intéressant
faciliter l'inscription sur les listes
électorales a baissé le vote des jeunes
à 16 ans autant de sujets que le
mouvement les engagés souhaiterait voir
à l'agenda du gouvernement des solutions
qui selon eux pourrait aider les jeunes
à se réconcilier avec la politique
génération désenchantée c'est le thème
de notre débat je vais vous faire un
aveu ce matin ça c'était sur france
inter j'écoutais ce qu'il a dit était
interrogée dans la dans la matinale et
nicolas demorand a parlé de génération
désenchantée j'ai eu ça dans la tête
toute la journée
voyez ce que je veux dit donc
pour les fans de mylène farmer c'est
super pour les autres vous êtes dans le
même cas pas maintenant vous l'avez
jusqu'à tard ce soir bien génération
désenchantée sérieusement on ne veut pas
résumer votre livre si ward shoah ça le
livre que vous avez écrit avec frédéric
dabi bonjour bonsoir le titre c'est la
fracture il est publié aux éditions les
arènes nous a donné envie voilà de
prendre le temps de débattre sur la
jeunesse française d'aujourd'hui
j'accueille également camille etienne
bonjour et bienvenue vous êtes étudiante
à sciences po activiste écologiste alors
on écologique on vous a découvertes et
puis il ya un moment où on fait croire
qu'on arrête de faire référence à cette
vidéo mais on a découverte avec une
vidéo réveillons-nous qui avaient été
diffusés sur ces thèmes et 2020 c'est ça
et on en est à plus de 15 millions de
vues rémy cardon bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénateur de la somme membres du
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains et vous êtes le benjamin du
sénat du haut de vos 27 ans dont vous
êtes coeur de cible pour l'étude de
stewart show et frédéric dabi et puis
évidemment matthieu croissandeau qui est
un peu mais moi non plus je pense que
c'est vraiment pas moi le benjamin du
plateau en tout cas merci d'être
toujours à mes côtés alors oui on peut
il faut dire un tout petit mot delà du
making of en quelque sorte pardon de cet
anglicisme mais vous avez réactiver une
enquête ifop qui sur les 18 30 ans qui
avaient été lancées par françoise giroud
1957 ensuite ça a été réactualisé tous
les dix ans et sage l'an 2000 à peu près
10 999 et là aujourd'hui pour cette
génération 2020 on dit on va dire ça
comme ça vous parler de fracture le mot
est fort pourquoi ce mot en fait et
c'est la fracture on pourrait dire même
les fractures parce qu'effectivement il
ya une fracture sur certains sujets
entre les plus jeunes et leurs aînés
mais aussi une fracture qui est très
importante à l'intérieur même de cette
jeunesse parce qu'on jeunesse là c'est
pas un bloc monolithique
c'est une jeunesse qui est traversée par
des expériences très multiples avec des
réalités aussi de vie très différente et
donc d appréhension du monde des
engagements aussi qui diffèrent et puis
une fracture comme vous l'avez 10 entre
les différentes jeunesse des différentes
générations et je pense que l'intérêt de
ce bouquin est à la fois de retracer un
petit peu lire et l'historique de c2c
jeunesse là pour pouvoir les comparer
quand c'est comparable sur des
indicateurs qui nous semblait
intéressant et c'est aussi peut-être
un petit peu dépassé toutes les
étiquettes que l'on a cole à cette
jeunesse là parce qu'elle est
insaisissable et la séduisante que les
étiquettes et donc et donc c c et c
dépassé toutes ces étiquettes là dans
lesquelles elle se reconnaît pas
forcément cette jeunesse et puis et puis
moi personnellement ce que je fais
partie de ces 18 30 je me suis aussi
surpris parfois en écrivant ce bouquin
face à des résultats à être surpris
positivement négativement donc c est
plus un un dialogue et voilà un outil du
débat quand on qu'on essaie de proposer
ce mot fracture camille ne tienne est-ce
que vous l'entendez de quelle première
fracture vous vient à l'esprit peut-être
votre combat écologiste de 2 voilà c'est
quoi votre première fracture pour cette
génération j'ai vraiment senti une
fracture générationnelle surtout après
la preuve qu vide et pendant cette
pandémie où on a ce tabou un peu des
générations qui est vraiment redevenu
aussi sur la place publique comme un
objet de débat on à l'imaginaire de
d'une jeunesse sacrifiée l'imaginaire du
boomer aussi kaka réapparu dans le débat
public et donc de plus en plus moi on
m'a soit enfermé dans quelqu'un qui
était forcément contre la génération
d'avant qui lui en voulait terriblement
de me laisser ce monde la vaisselle
tonalité dans votre première vidéo est
bien orienté se fendra parce que la
deuxième qui va sortir dans quelques
semaines il m à la génération d'avant
que j'ai écrites pour ma grand mère et
qui en fait 10 a dit qu'on se trompe de
combat et que
l'imaginaire de dire on se bat pour les
générations futures pour l'héritage
qu'on va laisser n'est plus vrai
aujourd'hui on a vu cet été avec l'été
dramatique on a eu tous les catastrophes
environnementales
je crois que c'est très ancré dans la
génération d'aujourd'hui que on se bat
pour maintenant et donc on a besoin
aussi de collaborer avec tous les gens
qui sont déjà dans l'espoir de pouvoir
et donc ça inclut la génération entre
guillemets d'avant donc c'est plutôt une
main tendue en fait que je veux faire et
c'est sortir de ce de cette fracture
peut-être sortir de la fracture
générationnelle votre fracture celle que
vous retenez vous si vous pensez à la à
la jeunesse aux 18-30 ans vous diriez
quoi c'est effectivement une génération
va des années 90 qui a vécu une
multitude de crises que ce soit la crise
de leurs parents sur la crise financière
en 2008 et aujourd'hui la crise du coc
vide et est ce que je ressens c'est
effectivement les attentats aussi les
attentes et aussi également et puis
c'est du coup des gouvernements qui
successifs qui ont géré des crises et
pas forcément on réfléchit à un projet
d'avenir et c'est le manque de
perspectives aussi qui créent ces
fractures je pense alors on va on va
vraiment détaillé certains éléments de
cette étude qui est passionnante et je
reprends ce titre elle a très
sérieusement génération désenchantée
sais c'est pas un hasard parce que moi
j'ai été frappé par sa c'était
fondremand du niveau de bonheur chez les
jeunes en 20 ans de combien de 2.3 que
ces 27 - 27 c'est énorme et pourquoi
surtout de quoi être explorent déjà il
faut nuancer la jeunesse est quand même
heureux c'est reconnaître sur la la le
score au global à peu près vu un peu
plus de 80% des jeunes qui s'estime
heureux mais c'est sur l'intensité du
bonheur où effectivement les jeunes qui
se disait très heureux en 99 versus
cette génération là on perd 27 points
les explications on essaie de le montrer
dans moins de fourie compris souris qui
sont peut-être plus comment dire plus
incertain voyez c'est peut-être plus
difficile dans cette dans cette
époque-là de se dire ou de se déclarer
et non et c'est dans ce bouquin de
donner quelques éléments quelques
indicateurs sont des indicateurs
d'opinion c'est tout là il faut prendre
tout ça avec avec la une nuance mais
c'est un outil intéressant aussi pour
observer comment ce niveau de bonheur
dégringole nous on a perçu de trois
indicateurs qui nous semblait très
intéressant la première chose est ce que
l'on disait ce sénateur s'est
effectivement cette jeunesse un petit
peu désenchanté c'est à dire que on a
une perte d'idéal dans la jeunesse qui
est absolument frappante c'est à dire
qu'on ne croit plus on ne sait plus vers
quelle société on veut aller la société
désirable de demain elle est extrêmement
illisible ça revient aussi quelqu'un de
tout à fait d'accord et où est ce que
c'est une perte de 10 des halles où il
ya plus un grand idéal mais ce mais il
ya des générations qui en fait il ya
même des causes qui sont prêts à se
battre pour des causes qui ont certains
idéaux alors c'est on va parler de
évidemment- écologiquement sûr les deux
religions par exemple l'anitea nos sens
politique du terme gérer c'est à dire
que c'est plus l'expression d'une
défiance envers le politique qui
incarnerait un projet de société qui
effectivement un idéal avec des
aspirations mais c'est vraiment l'idéal
au sens politique et puis après il ya
une deuxième un deuxième indicateur qui
semble assez intéressant notamment en
sortie de crise ducobu c'est le
sentiment que l'on vit dans une époque
malchanceuse alors ça c'est très
frappant il ya une réelle fracture entre
les entre les générations et en soit la
génération 999 en l'occurrence c'est que
on est face à une génération qui estime
que vivre à cette époque est une
malchance et ça pour le coup malgré la
multitude de crises que les générations
passées ont dû faire face aujourd'hui on
a un élément qui est nouveau c'est
l'urgence des crises et l'urgence des
réponses à apporter oui alors il ya un
mois je trouve ça intéressant parce
qu'il ya ce désenchantement est ce qu'on
peut dire que du désenchantement à la
contestation parfois la contestation
violente il n'ya qu'un pas ou que
quelques pas et que ça c'est un risque
politique tout à fait sain risques
politiques et puisque je ressens aussi
ça a été aussi décrit dans le livre
c'est la perte enfin dire est que les
corps intermédiaires sont en perte de
vitesse pour structurer une pensée pour
donner un horizon et c'est celle alors
l'enjeu est aussi de de demain pour que
notre démocratie soient soignés c'est
qu'elle leur fait que les corps
intermédiaires reprennent
de la vie et donne envie de vienne à je
dirais attractif au sens
propre du terme pour la jeunesse c'est à
dire que on vient s'engager dans un
parti politique on vient s'engager dans
un syndicat pour en ayant tout cas des
idées à défendre une vision de ces de
savoir où on va en s'impliquant et en
adhérant et donc voilà le aujourd'hui ce
qu'on ressent quand même c'est le fait
qu'il y ait dans nos sociétés un manque
de d'attractivité dans les corps
intermédiaires ça a créé des
morcellements et l'éthique et la
démocratie vous allez voter
c'est de motiver je pense que mon rôle
dans cette élection sera de faire en
sorte que le climat et les l'urgence
climatique soit vraiment discuté sont un
thème de campagne sérieux et qu'on est
ce qu'on fait c'est comme ça qu'on va
aussi mobiliser les jeunes c'est en
parlant des questions que vous êtes
pouvoir qu'ils sont leurs questions qui
sont aussi les thèmes de société de
notre génération et pour qu'on s'y
retrouve pour qu'on a envie de se
mobiliser par le vote il faut que les
questions qui nous touchent en premier
soit discutée sinon comment mobiliser
alors je crois que le taux d'abstention
lors de la dernière élection il avait le
passé qu est la rédactrice en chef de
l'émission va me va m'envoyer la fille
c'était aux dernières régionales et
départementales c'est 87% alors
évidemment on peut espérer plus de
participation à la présidentielle mais
je vous donnais l'apport de mathieu mais
il faut de comment les jeunes évidemment
je veux dire c'est impossible répondent
à la question mais j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient quand même une différence entre
les 18 24 et les 25-30 c'est quoi cette
différence mais c'est une fracture à un
terrain de la génération des jeunes
générations c'est qu'on a effectivement
des
18-24 qui reste je dirais un peu plus
optimistes quant à l'engagement
politique c'est à dire qu'il ya une
forme de vanité du vote qui s'expriment
peut-être un petit peu moins génération
la plus jeune lorsque vous passer la
barre des jeunes et des frênes cinq ans
et après ce que l'espoir déçu du premier
vote qui n'a servi à rien qui n'a pas eu
de résultats et donc soit ils se
tournent un peu plus verte vers des
votes on va dire extrême est absolument
donc on a une radicalité qui peut
s'exprimer par exemple comme le symptôme
aussi d'une crise de résultats est ce
qu'on vient de se dire est très
intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est
face à une jeunesse qui estime que les
changements du monde de demain et des
enjeux qui l'ont identifié ne
procéderont pas du politique il ya une
grave crise de la représentativité à la
fois des enjeux et cette jeunesse dans
le nord le monde prises les 18-24 ils
pourraient voter macron alors toujours
il faut prendre les chiffres avec
prudence mais sur le
rapport de force politique que l'on a
décrit dans le livre effectivement il ya
une polarité entre les 18-24 qui sont
plus sur l'électorat macro est plutôt
les 25-30 surreprésentés dans
l'électorat de marine le pen par exemple
toujours de la prudence quand on est
toujours vendeur et conscrites l'opinion
ça c'est très important et nous les
journées c'est l'oubli parfois de le
rappeler le bilan des macros avec la
jeunesse apporte forcément été simple on
va dire ça comme ça non on écoute je
vous propose d'écouter une petite phrase
qui résume assez bien ce qui ressemble
au fond un rendez vous manqué entre
emmanuel macron la jeunesse écoutez
c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2020 c'est dur
donc je donnerais jamais de leçon à nos
jeunes parce que ce sont ceux qui
honnêtement vivent un sacrifice terrible
des examens annulé
de l' angoisse pour les formations de l'
angoisse pour trouver le premier job
nous sommes le 14 octobre dernier avait
reconnu et le président la république
n'a offrir la jeunesse qu'une forme de
compassion faux souvenirs sur les jeunes
on était quand même largement oubliée au
début de la pandémie en tout cas on
parlait beaucoup des personnes les plus
fragiles et dont des personnes âgées à
protéger mais qui se soucie à l'époque
des étudiants désocialisés des enfants
déscolarisés on en parlait pas beaucoup
il a fallu que ça arrive une fois la fin
de l'année voit au début de cette année
ci et puis cette petite phrase emmanuel
macron elle a beaucoup fait réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux à l'époque parce que
depuis son élection au fond macro n'a
jamais semblé vraiment trouver les mots
pour s'adresser à la jeunesse locale
c'est quand même le président le plus
jeune que la france et cuba oui 1 39 ans
son élection c'est un sacré paradoxe et
pourtant on le dit parfois plus vieux
que son âge dans sa tête parce qu'ils
emploient des formules parfois issus
d'un français qu'on ne parle plus parce
que ses références culturelles qui ont
beau être référence littéraire
absolument incroyable camille j de ne
pas pas forcément toujours à la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui est une journaliste qui
s'appelle tissu le code qui avait écrit
au moment de son élection macron at il
écoutés nirvana radiohead vibré devant
pulp fiction ou la haine était amusé par
l'épisode du prince de bel air bien
qu'il soit né en 77 rien n'indique qu'il
n'ait jamais été vraiment de notre
génération écrit vettel est de fait par
quoi commencer le quinquennat vaincrons
par la baisse des apl vous souvenez de
cette baisse des apl qui touchait même
si c'était pour quelques euros mais
c'était vraiment une incompréhension de
la part de l'exécutif les étudiants mais
de cette baisse des appels aux
manifestations contre les violences
policières en passant par on en a parlé
de la mobilisation pour le climat le
fossé s'est creusé il faudra attendre la
toute dernière partie du quinquennat
pour que l'entourage du président
commence à se soucier de parler à la
frange jeune de son lectorat est donc là
on est dans un changement de stratégie
changement de corps oui alors changement
de support il investit les réseaux
sociaux ils parlent sur type top five
des messages bonne rentrée à tous il
s'invite en décembre sur brut le média
en ligne en disant ça ça va parler aux
jeunes puis après c'est le festival on a
le droit à la convocation de l'elysée de
mcfly et carlito pour faire des
galipettes dans le jardin l'opposition
c'est ouf rien là qui écrit aux gadgets
et en même temps la vidéo et beaucoup vu
du coup le sentiment est
venu ensuite une potacherie on est un
petit peu quand même et puis et puis là
il ya des gestes un peu plus politique
qui s'annonce en tout cas notamment
cette réflexion sur le revenu
l'engagement pour la jeunesse qui te
font une forme de rsa jeunes qui ne
dirait pas son nom avec évidemment des
droits et des devoirs philosophie -
cronje oblige mais reste à savoir si ce
revirement de dernière minute il se
traduira dans les urnes au soir de
l'élection vous en parliez en 2017
emmanuel macron était arrivée en
troisième position chez les jeunes
derrière jean luc mélenchon et marine le
pen
je voudrais qu'on remercie mathieu pour
pour cette analyse qu'on rebondisse sur
ce que vous venez de dire est qu'on se
pose la question du vote écolo est ce
que parce que vous vous portez ses idées
dans vos dans vos engagements mais si
votre choix est ce que ce qu'ils vont
voter écolo est ce que parce que
l'urgence écologique elle et elle est au
coeur de cette génération lorsqu'elle
est ressenti profondément par cette
génération parce qu'une grande partie de
cette génération d est-ce que ça va
jusqu'au vote et au vote pour le parti
qui représente le plus cesser ces enjeux
déjà deux fois le premier pas c'est
effectivement l'environnement c'est
l'enjeu de la jeunesse mais pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
c'est une génération un peu c'est pas ma
faute pour rester dormir dans les
références puisqu'on et voilà on hérite
aussi de conséquence de choix que l'on a
pas accord n'a pas fait donc on est les
actifs et maintenant j'ai c'est pas ma
faute à moi
c'est vous pour varier les plaisirs donc
c'est une génération qui se détermine
comme un acteur légitime pour répondre
et naturels pour répondre à cette à cet
enjeu depuis le deuxième pour répondre à
votre question le deuxième indicateur
c'est que pour répondre à ces enjeux
écologiques c'est un petit peu l'aude à
l'action individuelle c'est à dire qu'on
ne crois pas du tout que c'est aux
politiques que le politique va répondre
aux enjeux individuels donc c'est le
citoyen qui est le plus à même en tout
cas dans l' enquête que l'ordre que l'on
mène est dans le livre que l'on écrit
qui est le plus à même de lutter
efficacement contre contre lâchant
climatique et puis donc est ce qu'ils
vont voter europe écologie pour vous
dire les choses très franchement il ya
10% des jeunes aujourd'hui qui font
confiance aux partis politiques pour
résoudre la crise climatique donc ça
fait quand même niveau de confiance qui
est très très faible et il faut avouer
aussi que l'adhésion à europe
ecologie-les verts est assez molle chez
les peluches et des plus jeunes même si
effectivement sur les dernières
élections intermédiaires le vote jeunes
en faveur d'europe écologie faire
basculer quelques villes on se rappelle
aux municipales aux régionales mais il
faut dire aussi que sur les intentions
de vote qu'ils ont fait aujourd'hui le
parti écologique quel que soit le leader
qui sera désigné ne fait pas le plat le
plan auprès de auprès de la jeunesse
qu'hamilton wiiware réagir oui je jure
d'être une petite nuance sur ses bâtons
à mon sens empiriquement ce que
j'observe c'est pas tant une plus grande
volonté de faire poser sa sueur sur
l'individu citoyen et non pas le
collectif qui se traduirait uniquement
par la responsabilité politique ne
serait pas uniquement porté par les
représentants parce qu'il ya vraiment
une une radicalisation aussi dans les
mouvements écologiques sociaux qui fait
qu'on prend conscience que tout ne doit
pas poser sur l'individu justement on à
l'étude de carbone 4 qui a été largement
partagée en disant c'est tous les
français étaient parfaitement écolo
réduire est que de 25 % nos émissions
75% restants faisant donc sur
l'entreprise et l'état mais je pense que
c'est plutôt un rapport de force une
sorte d'agonac en train de se retrouver
et c'est donc comment faire pression sur
les politiques parce que quand on a nous
au début du quinquennat un président qui
au niveau international ce se prétend
être le champion de la terre qu'on a dû
promettre
des états unis absolument de l'accord de
paris que la france ne respecte pas du
tout par ailleurs non plus c'est pas
parce qu'elle reste dedans qu'elle suit
la trajectoire donc à quoi bon
finalement des jolies paroles qui ne
sont pas suivies d'actes pour moi c'est
plutôt ça en fait c'est de se dire quand
on a une parole présidentielle qui à
l'ère des réseaux sociaux en fait on
peut avec les vidéos à voir ma groupe
qui dit les yeux dans les yeux des
citoyens je tiendrai vos promesses la
commençons semaine pour le climat qui
quelques mois près torpille ça je pense
que c'est plutôt un manque de confiance
et non pas un manque et non pas le fait
de sa prestation individuelle et me
cardon comment inverser cette tendance
déjà il part du principe que la
politique c'est un consensus à trouver
avec une communauté d'individus et donc
quand j'ai ça c'est que aujourd'hui
l'app l'écologie est quand même utilisé
par les partis politiques mais pas
qu'eux aussi les associations qui sur
une forme de marketing politique et pas
justement une vision
avec un sens un sens commun dans le dos
l'objectif de transformer la société je
prends un exemple très concret c'est de
passer d'un marketing politique à
l'écologie populaire pour que j'emploie
ce mot là
volontairement parce que je prends un
exemple dans mon département on est les
très bons élèves sur la transition
énergétique puisque on a plus de mille
1000 éoliennes qu'on a un huitième du
parc éolien français ce qui est énorme
pour un département donc dans la somme
dans la somme tout à fait sauf qu'en
l'occurrence on est allé très vite là
dessus on a été même embarqué dans
beaucoup de marketing et les élus en ont
profité et des retombées énormes sur
financière sur le sur les communes mais
c'est pas acceptée par la majorité la
majorité de la population est là le
problème c'est qu'il ya pendant ce
temps-là est des situations où sur un
rayon de sept kilomètres il ya 150
éoliennes et donc les habitants sont en
train de se poser la question comment je
peux pas vivre avec les nuances sonores
toute ma vie aucune chute de
l'immobilier je vous donne des exemples
très concrets c'est comment
les les combats qu'on peut mener comment
on les rend beaucoup plus populaire et
démocratique enfin d'écran démocratiser
pardon
nous permettant de faire des tas accepté
par toute la population entraîne une
forte majorité c'est pour ça que les
résultats ne sont pas là à dire que pour
pourquoi les jeunes effectivement
s'empare de la question écologique sur
tous les mouvements la marche pour le
climat et toutes les associations qui
vont avec mais sait on voit que c'est
une catégorie de ces jeunes et pas
l'immense majorité alors il ya un mot
qu'on va employer maintenant c'est le
mot éco anxiété je demande à quand un
calme et 2 de revenir sur le plateau de
100 publique la chronique de la
rédaction quentin c'est une étude qui a
été réalisée pour la revue 97 on parle
de la plus vaste étude réalisée sur les
craintes des jeunes liés au dérèglement
climatique tout à fait aux malheurs
d'ailleurs c'est pas une chronique est
très positive que je vais vous dire
parce que les chiffres que je voudrais
sont pas très réjouissant l'étude
publiée par cette très prestigieuse
revue zélande 7 elle est d'origine
britannique
des chercheurs ont interrogé comme cela
dix mille jeunes entre 16 et 25 ans dans
dix pays dont la france on retient ce
chiffre que je vous donne tout de suite
40% 45% même des jeunes disent que leur
inquiétude sur la situation climatique
et bien elle a des effets négatifs sur
leur vie quotidienne on aller dans le
détail d'autres chiffres qu'on a trouvé
intéressant avec un constat qu'on peut
dire alarmant sur plusieurs points et
les 75 % des jeunes du monde entier un
trouve l'avenir effrayant 56 % des
jeunes pensent que l'humanité et
condamné 55% et bien disent qu'ils ont
au moins deux opportunités que leurs
parents ce taux monte même à 61% pour
les jeunes français qui sont interrogés
dans l'étude et enfin 39 % de ces jeunes
interrogés disent hésité à avoir des
enfants oui c'est un peu ce que disait
ricard dont tout à l'heure des jeunes
sont sévères sur l'action le bilan de
leur gouvernement tout à fait c'est le
deuxième volet de cette étude publiée
par zélande 7 c'est l'autre enseignement
effectivement selon les 16 25 ans qui
sont interrogés bien les gouvernements
ne s'occupe pas suffisamment des jeunes
une majorité pense qu'ils ont trahi les
générations futures seuls 31 % des
jeunes interrogés pensent que leur
gouvernement en fait assez en matière de
changement climatique et sur cette
partie là de l'enquêté bien les français
les jeunes français sont encore plus
critiques que les autres jeunes qui sont
interrogés merci beaucoup merci quentin
pour ceux se nomme donc sur sept en tête
cette enquête cette étude de la revue ce
de 27 aces que ça veut dire qu ami
etienne vous voulez vous le portez aux
6,7 cette anxiété vous la portez une
certaine façon que elle peut se
transformer parfois on vous présentait
comme une activiste
ça veut dire vous allez jusqu'où dans
l'activisme et vous voyez où et jusqu'au
à ma question jusqu'à la violence mais
jusqu'à ce que ça marche et en fait
c'est la question est aussi la réponse
aussi simple que que la question nous
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que puisse y avoir des conditions de vie
sur terre viable qu'on puisse continuer
à avoir dans un vivre dans un monde qui
ne sera pas +4° +5° war 7° à la fin du
siècle parce qu'on va le connaître c'est
aussi simple que ça en fait c'est se
battre pour la vie pour la possibilité
de la voir et donc donc ça peut aller
jusqu à l'action violente met donc en
fait que c'est le seul moyen donc ça va
je crois c est sa pause de deux semaines
on vous attend vous savez pourquoi je
vous pose la question parce que dans
notre étude ya un jeune sur cinq qui se
dit prêt à mourir pour la cause
environnementale
plutôt mourir pour la france c'est
est-ce que c'est déjà le cas il ya un
nombre d'activistes et une étude alors
j'ai pas le chiffre exact vous
rechercherez chez vous mais nombre
d'activistes climatiques qui sont à
travers le monde assez signer
aujourd'hui est assez démentiel enfin
aujourd'hui à des gens qui meurent de se
battre pour ce combat là donc nous quand
on a le privilège de pas le faire
forcément qu'on se dit qu'on peut on se
doit aussi de porter ça avec conviction
maman il pose la question de quelle
violence pourquoi à part qu'est ce qu'on
en est ce qu'on définit la violence que
c'est sur des biens ce que sur des
personnes moi j'ai décidé de me battre
dans la non violence parce que ma
position le permet aussi et je pense
être pertinente à cet endroit là je peux
même témoigner elle et elle était
présente au parlement ce soit à
l'assemblée ou au sénat pour voilà oui
mais vous rêvez car nos
engagements
je me permets de prendre la parole juste
pour faire le lien avec la question
d'activisme et l'écho inquiéter les
comptes y était en fait c'est aussi
faire un deuil on doit faire un deuil
psychologique d'un monde qu'on nous a
vendu comme possible et qui ne l'est pas
à cette consommation effrénée semis de
la croissance en fillon doit faire le
deuil de sa et donc on passe par
différentes phases du deuil il ya le
choc il ya la tristesse les banques
citées on est la première manifestation
las olas tlj aussi on l'appelle et
appris à l'action de l'acceptation et
aller de l'avant et donc l'activisme et
peut-être la meilleure des réponses à
l'éco anxiété et alors c'est pour ça que
je vous repose la question vous n'êtes
pas un activiste vous avez fait un autre
choix qui est le plus efficace
les deux sont essentiels
je pense avoir répondu à la question non
mais c'est à dire que aujourd'hui on a
besoin aussi de s'imprégner d'une
certaine volonté et d'engagement de 2,2
collectif sur le
midi en tout cas contre l'urgence
climatique et mais nous on a besoin de
s'emparer de leurs propositions de voir
comment on peut et les rendre
accessibles et es et les maîtres les
installer dans la réalité de la société
sqy aussi ça aussi de trouver le curseur
quand je lis heures c'est trouver un
consensus avec un une communauté
d'individus pour faire accepter les
propositions c'est la difficulté du
politique aujourd'hui que l'un et
l'autre font de la politique tout à fait
tous incluant mais chacun et moi ce qui
me fascine dans cette génération c'est
qu'elle n'a jamais été autant connectés
que les générations précédentes tout
pour la diffusion des idées partage des
connaissances ça n'a jamais été voilà il
suffit maintenant de vous le dites vous
pourrez faire j'ai téléchargé sachez
vous trouvez ça sur les réseaux sociaux
jamais la mobilisation d'une certaine
façon n'a été aussi facile
qu'aujourd'hui parce que la mise en
réseau permet ça donc il ya c'est cette
génération là à des leviers d'action que
ce soit sur l'activisme que ce soit même
sous une forme de représentation
peut-être des nouveaux partis les corps
intermédiaires ont sauté les vieux
partis n'attire plus les jeunes mais en
tout cas il ya la possibilité d'investir
le champ politique et de nourrir c'est
extrêmement juste et c'est un petit peu
aussi
l'une des idées un peu phare de ce
bouquin c'était pour donner un peu d'eux
d'élan positif à ces chiffres là c'est
de montrer que l'environnement c'est
l'enjeu de la jeunesse parce que c'est
leur jeu sur lequel la jeunesse est
peut-être la plus diffusée au nist au
sens où c'est l'enjeu sur laquelle sur
lequel pardon la jeunesse et la plus
influente oui
génération apparaît jeu et on trouve en
tout cas avec ce day dhabi cela très
positif
la fracture aller pour le coup parfois
aussi nécessaire quand il s'agit de
montrer l'exemple quand il s'agit de
réinventer des choses et ré inventer des
choses c'est à la fois aussi réinventer
les espaces politiques et sur
l'environnement ce qui est très
intéressant où il avait dit très
justement c'est que la jeunesse s'empare
de 7,7 en jeu là aussi en réinventant un
espace politique n'est plus forcément
l'espace politique traditionnel mais qui
peut être aussi les canaux d'information
les réseaux sociaux et donc ça c'est
c'est aussi pour le coup quelque chose
de poser sa touche toutes les jeunesses
y compris les jeunesses plus issus de
quartiers plus populaires c'est très
intéressant parce qu'effectivement sur
cette question de clivage sur l'enjeu
écologique on a beaucoup moins de
clivage intra générationnelle que sur
les autres enjeux sur les valeurs et
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est que
l'écologie un petit peu comme
l'expérience coville je dirais agit
comme une sorte comme un sorte d'élément
fondamental de la mémoire collective
jeunes c'est à dire c'est quelque chose
arrive et qu'elle nous sommes nés et qui
fédère assez bien l'ensemble des
catégories de jeunes nés ce cas une
fracture entre les jeunes des cités et
les autres est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous avez essayé de sondés qui
est facile à sonder ou parler alors ce
qui est ce qui est compliqué alors de
des cités on peut on peut on peut pas
aller je sais tu que jusqu'à 7
granularité agréé de de précision par
contre on a posé une question de ce
qu'on appelle signalétique c'est-à-dire
pour essayer de voir les différents
profils de jeunes et on leur a posé la
question de leur sentiment
d'appartenance à une classe sociale et
ce qui est très intéressant c'est
qu'effectivement il y a des fractures
assez notable entre des jeunes qui se
considèrent issus de quartiers ou de
milieux défavorisés et des jeunes qui se
considère plutôt privilégié je vous
donne un exemple parce qu'on a commencé
avec ce chiffre là sur le niveau de
bonheur
vous avez un clivage très très net entre
ceux entre les jeunes qui sont issus de
quartiers défavorisés qui se sentent un
petit peu plus vulnérables mais aussi
qu'ils se sentent un petit peu moins
intégrés en france c'est à dire ceux qui
ont le sentiment d'être un peu moins
fier d'être français d'être un peu moins
intégrés on a un niveau de bonheur qui a
encore moins important donc oui
effectivement c'est socialement on sait
clivé socialement jeunes alors une image
des jeunes des cités notamment en seine
saint denis c'est pour cela que se bat
diandra tchatchouang qui est avec nous
en visioconférence en direct bonsoir dix
ans d'un merci d'être avec nous est
médaillé d'argent à tokyo avec l'équipe
de france de basket ball championne de
france et femmes engagés c'est pour ça
que j'ai souhaité vous participiez à
l'émission vous avez créé deux
associations il ya texture choc pour
sensibiliser les jeunes filles à la
pratique du sport et puis stonewall qui
est en fait une une aide aux devoirs
pourquoi vous pensez on parle des
valeurs dans cette émission pourquoi
vous pensez que le sport c'est une
valeur forte un outil de deux peut-être
même de liberté pour les jeunes filles
pour les jeunes femmes
bonsoir
écoutez je pense que le sport c'est
vraiment un endroit qui rassemble savait
que notre société a beaucoup
d'endroits où malheureusement on est
souvent vue est définie par nos origines
notre milieu social et le sport vraiment
c'est le terrain sur lequel on a un
objectif commun et peu importe nos
différences on en sait on essaie en tout
cas d'en faire une force et donc cette
association c'est quoi ce que vous
proposez aux jeunes filles
alors techno shot c'est un évènement
100% féminin en seine-saint-denis moi
j'ai grandi à la courneuve donc je me
suis dit en fait que je voulais mettre
en place quelque chose qui permettrait
au jeune fille de s'identifier à travers
des modèles d inspiration ces mini donc
le but c'est de favoriser la pratique
féminine sportive d'ailleurs mon sponsor
prévoit un budget pour pour financer les
licences parce que pour certains foyers
malheureusement c'est souvent le souci
pour inscrire les enfants au sport mais
aussi de faire échanger des jeunes qui
avec des parcours d'excellence féminine
donc on a eu des journalistes avec anne
laure bonnet rokhaya diallo on a eu
aussi des anciennes sportives à 17 ans
une ancienne miss france en fait c'est
de but c'est vraiment de faire à
deux inspirés les 26 oui science faut
des icônes ou des ou des modèles on peut
on peut dire ça comme ça l'image de
votre département danse chez nous là
dans les médias comment vous l'apercevez
je pense qu'elle est souvent chaud c'est
malheureusement je pense qu'on parle
souvent de la même chose moi j'ai fait
le choix de porter comme numéro de
maillot le 93 parce que pour moi c'était
une opportunité d'en parler en bien
justement et c'est pas con le composent
la question parce que la réalité c'est
qu'il s'y passe aussi des choses bien
et je pense que malheureusement lui
cette image allait elle est fausse et à
travers mon association stadium qui est
un dispositif de soutien scolaire à la
base on a envie que la jeunesse de
seine-saint-denis puisse participer
prochainement aux jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 parce que pour
nous c'est important que qu'elle joue un
rôle aussi et qu'elles soient pas
oubliés parce que malheureusement lui
dans les médias souvent l'image qui
ressort du 93 est très souvent négatives
bon c'est aussi pour ça que je voulais
vous invitez voilà on fait notre petit
pas c'était quoi la couleur de votre
médaille à tokyo
je me suis trompé je vous ai joué donner
de l'argent mais vous avez entendu des
manuels lagrange
est attendu discours des macros sportif
français médaillés vous a mis une
pression de dingue pour gagner 80
médailles de plus
à paris donc qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire ce à dire gt gt search est
effectivement un discours je pense
présent bissieux je pense que c'était à
la hauteur de talent qui a en cette
équipe de france olympique et
paralympique
après il faudra mettre les moyens pour
que l'on puisse continuer à s'entraîner
et se préparer dans des conditions
optimales
merci beaucoup dit andrea chong bravo
pour votre engagement et bon vent avec
votre équipe de montpellier je crois
pour le championnat de france 2 de
basket il nous reste un peu moins de
quatre minutes je voudrais qu'on parle
d'eux on termine avec la famille parce
que moi ça m'a surpris dans votre dans
votre livre dans votre
merci tiendra les 10 mots préférés des
18-30 ans celui qui vient en premier
c'est la famille est ce que ça vous a
surpris vous aussi oui alors oui et non
oui oui à titre personnel non je dirais
à titre collectif parce qu'on sort quand
même temps d'une parenthèse
qu'ovide il ya un effet domino bien sûr
qui a qui a marqué qui a marqué sept
générations la famille c'est à la fois
la protection c'est la valeur refuge
aussi quand on est dans cette dans ce
moment de de troubles et je pense que
c'est c'est presque heureux de voir que
pour le coup sur les valeurs on en parle
et qui a un rapprochement aussi des
valeurs entre les générations les plus
jeunes et les générations les plus âgées
donc oui à des fractures et je
commençais par par part nuancé en n'y a
pas de fracture sur tous les sujets on
peut y avoir des rapprochements pour le
disais on peut avoir des fractures aussi
nécessaire et sur les valeurs c'est vrai
en tout cas les dix mots préférés quoi
les 2 et 3 alors j'ai pu j'ai plus en
tête mais je crois que vous avez
vous avez sur les dix mots au moins six
mots des plus de 60 ans qui reviennent
dans les dix mots des accords dont il
ya une convergence moment une
convergence et ce qui est très
intéressant aussi pour rebondir sur ce
qui vient d'être dit c'est qu'on est
face à une jeunesse qui lie la société à
partir d'une grille de lecture qui qui
et les inégalités et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est très très fort et c'est
aussi un des éléments de notre étude et
j'y pense parce que votre intervenante
il faisait référence je pense qu'on est
vraiment sur une jeunesse qui peut être
perméable en radio kiss mais tu sais
mais qui qui qui sonne un peu le cri
d'alarmé en disant que sur toutes les
situations qu on énumère dans le bouquin
il y en a pas beaucoup en tout cas qui
sont satisfaisantes qui sont et qui vont
générer aussi des certaine colère sur un
ensemble de sujets alors il ya quelques
quelques chiffres intéressants sur les
enjeux par exemple d'égalité femmes
hommes etc
mais ça génère aussi des défiances et ça
va même jusqu'à déplorer un racisme
d'état un privilège blanc des choses
quand même qu'ils sont très surprenantes
et sur lesquelles il va falloir agir
politiquement là pour le coup autour
d'un discours parce que c'est quand même
un indicateur d'opinion qui qui pour
nous est absolument absolument frappant
remeka renonce à vous faire réagir oui
tout à fait assez d'accord avec l'étude
c'est à dire que le la perte de croyance
en quelque chose comme un produit pour
un jeune une position de 2,7 en
situation qu'on force et faire 2 2 voilà
deux pour la situation confort c'est la
famille c'est là où la religion
d'ailleurs ça peut être sur les deux 51%
des 18-30 ans croient en l'existence de
dieu les résultats de oui mais c'est lié
avec le désenchantement aussi dont on se
parlait dans ce cas est rare sur la
religion ont là aussi pour pour aller un
petit peu plus loin c'est pas tant la
religiosité sert la pratique religieuse
que là encore le respect des religions
certes comme on vient de le dire la
jeunesse voit la société très
discriminatoire très inégalitaire on
voit plus les questions de religion dont
la laïcité par exemple comme quelque
chose de contraignant de discriminatoire
que quelque chose qui permet le le vivre
ensemble est d'ailleurs juste un chiffre
offert pour faire réagir ses que sur le
triptyque républicain liberté égalité
fraternité il ya une fracture qui est je
trouve assez
expressif c'est les jeunes prône
l'égalité alors que les plus âgés prône
la liberté et donc c'est vraiment de
lecture pour le coup de la société qui
me semble assez intéressante et qui
génère aussi des conséquences dans
l'engagement assez probantes en devenir
que la gauche à un ami alors plus rien
c'était traditionnellement
g sortir de ce plateau je serai vieux je
serai pas désenchanté sa
merci beaucoup merci à tous les cadres
d'avoir participé à ce débat et ont donc
on conseille évidemment sinon on
n'aurait pas fait cela la lecture de
votre livre la fracture c'est donc co
écrit par frédéric dabi publié aux
éditions les arènes merci pour ce
travail qui j'espère va nourrir la
réflexion de beaucoup de candidats à la
présidentielle on l'espère mathieu
mathieu je vous laisse la main parce que
demain c'est c'est vous qui serez à ma
place exceptionnellement le
exceptionnellement mars arrivera
sûrement de temps dans la saison avec
plaisir l'acier le laplace et chaude le
siège et le siège est confortable vous
verrez prenez autant de plaisir que moi
je l'espère à la présentation de deux
sens public on se retrouve lundi
évidemment je remercie toutes les
équipes de public sénat pour voilà cette
première demie semaine on va dire
commune c'est du bonheur et on va
vraiment faire une belle saison j'en
suis convaincu demain matin
bonjour chez vous orientent dans city
qui reçoit philippe juvin
le maire l air de la garenne colombes
candidat aux primaires de la droite et
du centre médecin évidemment vous avez
beaucoup aussi sur les plateaux de télé
on salut à toutes et à tous